David, is there an actual scientific consensus
on what covid policy should be? This is a really
great question, because there are people who
hear the question, can't we just empirically
determine the right covid policy? And the
problem with the question is that it ignores
that every choice is subject to trade
offs. So I'll give you an example.
It has been determined beyond a doubt that given.
That the contagion is mostly happening indoors,
if you limit indoor exposure without masks to
other people, you dramatically reduce your risk
of giving to giving or getting the virus from
someone. Most contagion is happening within homes
and it's being brought in from elsewhere. And
of course, you reduce the risk of bringing it in
from elsewhere. If when you go to work, if you're
working indoors or go to the grocery store or you
wear a mask. OK, so it can be easy to say that's
the science. But when you talk about policy,
you're talking about a tradeoff. There are people
I disagree with them, but there are people.
I walked by a guy on the street the other day
who chastised me for wearing a mask in a bakery
as required by the bakery, who say, well, OK, that
may be the science of masks, but I don't believe
the trade off is worth it. The trade off being I
don't like the way I look and it's uncomfortable.
That's a trade off. And the science can't tell
you if that trade off is worth it because it
relates to values. Fundamentally, the the
bigger one, you know, that that would apply
is temporary shutdowns during spikes slow the
transmission when they are adhered to. And
there's a very interesting article I recently read
about. You know, a lot of Latin American countries
on paper have the strictest shutdowns and yet the
virus is out of control. What's happening? Well,
people aren't abiding by the shutdown and
there's no enforcement of the shutdown as
often as is the case. So even if you determine
temporary shutdowns that are very finely tuned
are clinically effective and they also minimize
societal harm in terms of economic harm,
and you're feeling like your personal liberties
have been taken away. These are like targeted, OK,
it's still a trade off, right? You still have to
say, well, this is the this scientific policy.
This policy has been shown scientifically to
reduce transmission by this amount. It lowers the
are not from something to something lower
than that. You still have a counter to that
and you still have to decide based on your
values, whether it's worth the trade off. So
I think that when we're asking the question,
what is the scientific consensus on covid policy,
what you're really saying is how much do different
policies reduce transmission? That the societal
question, the government question, the cultural
question, the economic question is what is the
economic cost? What is the psychological cost,
depression or separation of people, loneliness,
et cetera, economic, all this other stuff. And
that is a different question than simply what
works scientifically. And to me, I continue to
be shocked that people are insisting on this.
We we can't do all of this because we have to
save the economy. We can't shut down this. We
can't do that. We give all this all this different
stuff. How are people still thinking that it's
economy versus health, if we seriously
had dealt with the virus at the beginning,
there might have been an initial economic hit that
would have been harder. But we're a year in. We're
on Spike three. While most European countries
are only on the second spike, we've got one of
the highest death rates in the world. If you look
at the deaths relative to our population, it's
completely off the charts. So the the idea that
we're also dealing with false dichotomies about
it's either health or the economy, the economy
has suffered greatly and will continue to suffer.
And we're doing disastrously poorly when it when
it comes to health. So we might imagine that all
that matters is understanding the scientific
consensus like targeted and accu accurate,
really well done. Lockdown's work to
prevent the spread if people really do it.
But there are downsides. Depression, maybe people
drinking a business, permanently shutting down
economic problems, all that stuff. But there
is no consensus about what is worth it. And
that's where the conflict is coming from.
Now some people are making legal arguments.
A government, a state government mask mandate
is unconstitutional. No, it's not. But there are
real questions about what we believe is worth it,
and we came out on the wrong side of it, lastly,
that that's the important thing to know,
which is if we had actually had consensus
on, you know, a two month, we're 10
months in, we're almost a year. And
we had done a proper two month shutdown and really
done everything that that should have been done.
We could have had a relatively normal
summer in many parts of the of the country,
as many European countries did.
That's that's the unfortunate reality.
And getting consensus, we can better get
consensus on the scientific, even though you
still have people who say masks don't actually
work, shutdowns don't actually work. Well,
if people don't wear the masks correctly or if you
announce a shutdown but don't adhere to it yet,
that won't work. But if you do it right, it does.
Where we have not been able to get consensus
is what is worth doing and what are people
willing to tolerate. And part of it goes back
to the complete bungling by the federal government
at the very start of this entire thing. We've
got a great bonus show for you today.
Make sure to sign up and get instant
access at join Pakman Dotcom.
We'll see you on the bonus, Jeff.